صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
السيدات والساده ابدا كلمتي بتقديم جزيل
الشكر والامتنان الى خادم الحرمين
الشريفين جلاله الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ال سعود واليكم صاحب السمو الملكي ومن
خلالكم الى شعب المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الكريم على ما احطنا به من رعايه وحسن
وفاده منذ وصولنا الى هذه الارض المباركه
وان اهنئكم على توليكم رئاسه القمه في
دورتها الثانيه والثلاثين وادعو الله ان
يوفقكم الى ما فيه خير امتنا وشعبنا
ان المشهد الدولي يمر بواحده من اشد
الفترات خطوره في التاريخ المعاصر واراه
زمن استقطاب وتنافس هائل بين القوى الكبرى
على حساب القوى الاصغر او المنفرده ولذلك
فليس امام الدول العربيه في هذه المرحله
التاريخيه العظيمه سوى ان تستمسك بالمصالح
العربيه معيارا اساسيا للمواقف الدوليه
وان تلتزم بالتنسيق فيما بينها وبالعمل
الجماعي سبيلا اكيدا لتعزيز الكتله
العربيه في مواجهه ضغوط الاستقطاب
ان ازمات منطقتنا العربيه لم تجد للحل
طريقا بعد عقد واكثر من المعاناه والدماء
والالام فملايين العرب ما زالوا لاجئين
ونازحين واليوم اضيف اضيف الى احزان هذه
الامه حزن جديد في السودان يدفع المدنيون
ثمنا ضخما للمواجهه المسلحه التي فرضها
البعض على هذا البلد العزيز انا لتلك
المواجهات ان تتوقف وان تلتزم الاطراف
بمبدا الحوار صونا لدماء الشعب وحفاظا على
السودان ومقدراته ووحدته الترابيه وسلامه
مؤسساته الوطنيه
انني ادعو لان تكون قمه جده علامه بدء
لتفعيل حل عربي يوقف نزيف الدم في السودان
ويصحح اخطاء ارتكبت في الماضي وتوخى
المصلحه العليا للدوله السودانيه وليس
المصالح الضيقه لفئات او اشخاص
حقيقه سياده الرئيس اننا نسعى لايقاف نزيف
الدم والخسائر في كافه ميادين الاحتراب
الالي حيث لا منتصر ولا مهزوم والازمات
العربيه تشهد الان حاله من التجميد مقارنه
باوضاع اشد اشتعالا شاهدناها في السابق
خلال العقد الماضي وهي فرصه يتعين
اغتنامها من اجل تفعيل حلول العربيه لتلك
الازمات العربيه
ففي سوريا وارحب هنا بالرئيس بشار الاسد
بعد ان عادت سوريا الى مقعدها في هذا
المجلس الموقر ثمه فرصه لا ينبغي تفويتها
لمعالجه الازمه التي تعاني منها البلاد
لما يربو على العقد سواء في اسبابها
واصولها التي يظل الحل السياسي السبيل
الوحيد لتسويتها او في تبعاتها التي
تجاوزت حدود الوطن السوري
ويحضون الامل في ان يكون للعرب اسهامهم في
ايجاد الحلول الناجعه للاوجاع السوريه
العجيده
السيد الرئيس لقد عانت المنطقه العربيه
زمنا ولا تزال من التدخلات الاقليميه في
شؤونها ولم تنتج هذه التدخلات تنتج هذه
التدخلات سوى حصاد من التمزق والفرقه
والدم واليوم تمت اشارات على ان ننهج
الجيران يمكن ان يتغير انني ارحب مجددا
بالاتفاق الذي اوقع بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
في مارس الماضي فالعلاقات مع الجيران كافه
يجب ان تتاسس دوما على اساس من احترام
مبادئ حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول انها مبادئ اساسيه في
ميثاق الامم المتحده وهي مبادئ تتمسك بها
دولنا الوطنيه ولا تفرط فيها وتبقى فلسطين
الغاليه هما لا يحم لا يحمله اهلها وحدهم
لقد ادت الممارسات الرعناء لحكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الى تصعيد مروع في
منسوب العنف والقتل في الشهور الاخيره
انني احيي صمود الفلسطينيين في كل مكان في
الارض المحتله واقول ان السياسات
والممارسات الاستفزازيه لتلك الحكومه
الممعنه في التطرف والكراهيه لابد ان
تواجههم بتصدي حازم من مجتمع الدوليه عوضا
عما نشهده من صمت مريب ومشين سيد الرئيس
تم تحركه وحيويه في العمل العربي
والتجاهل واضح لاعاده امتلاج القضاء
امتلاك القضايا وتفعيل الادوار وان يتحول
العرب الى فاعلينا وليس مفعولا بهم واظن
ان هذه القمه في جده قمه التجديد والتغيير
تمثل خطوه مهمه طريق استعاده العرب لقضايا
وملفات طرقت للاخرين زمنا فتعقدت مساراتها
وتشبكت خيوطها اننا اليوم على عتبه طريق
صعب للانخراط الفاعل مع الازمات والسعي
لتسويتها وعلينا ان نسير فيه بكل العزم
والجهد حفاظا على امن الامه وشعوبها وصونا
لحاضرها ومستقبلها اتمنى لاعمال هذه القمه
كل النجاح والتوفيق شكرا سياده الرئيس
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات